thank you for coming to this talk my
title is a bit boring I just have all
the contents in it and yeah there's also
a bit better title for my motivation
behind it normally is work with - you
have two main problem if you have string
columns and they say object yeah slower
and there yeah it's not working really
good you can use categoricals but our
category goods are only work good if you
have a lower entropy and so if you do
much a lot of stuff for Strings it's
released though that's where my pain
started a bit to motivate this talk
about and what's the biggest benefit
coming out of here short thing about me
I'm a data scientist at Rwanda a company
doing automated replenishment in
supermarkets meaning we stock chefs in
supermarkets and ensure that nothing is
thrown away I work on the Apache arrow
and the Apache pocket project as a
project management committee long for
maintainer and I'm actually called data
scientist one I'm a data engineering
architect
meaning I have a lot of data I push
around with pandas I'm not doing so much
machine learning I'm just pushing data
around it's a basic introduction in the
talk today first want to motivate a bit
why why we want to have this why I
pandas as it is is not perfect that I
want to introduce the concept of
extension arrays which is an awesome new
feature in the latest release of pandas
I think it was about two or three weeks
ago so every in this talk you can use
with all pandas versions so please
update then I'm going to show you two
main ingredients I'm using two extant
pandas it's arrow as a storage back-end
and number two provide analytic on top
and I'm showing you how to combine all
that stuff and use in with your typical
pandas dataframe to understand a bit
better what a panda's data frame is or
what a series is the series is normally
made up of juvenile arrays you have to
payload data in my case here called
values and you have an index it's also
an numpy array giving a bit of data
alignment to the values a panda's data
frame in contrast to series just has
multiple of these values and - provides
really good analytical
is on that you can do filter crew by
aggregate and so on it's a huge set of
functions on top of a collection of
numpy series and most of the operations
in pandas they're generic they work for
every type that is supported by numpy
and they work also for the types that
are not supported by numpy which they're
called object D types but there's also
some kind of special operations like
accessing the day of week with a date or
doing string splitting and therefore you
haven't pandas these accesses may be dot
DT and dot STR the mouth of most
well-known that's really cool tool I
think probably most of the room already
have used pandas and it's really nice to
do data analysis but are also some
things which are not so nice the first
thing is which the main talk is about
pandas can only support it types that
numpy supports evils of heart a bit less
than um pi and in those cases you have a
data type coming from python it's not
supported in pandas you get the object D
type I'm also going to give you a short
introduction why this is really bad
this comes from a bit too non-price
focuses on numerical data and enhancers
the new modern word from matrices so you
normally have dimensions and in each
dimension data is fixed size one of the
typically example in contrast with that
is what was called NASA data when you
have NASA data you typically can have
say you have a pennis data frame you
have column in there and each row in the
column is a list of variable length
that's something which you can't
represent an array even if it's list of
integers but they have a variable length
and that's not matching the concept what
numpy is doing for us so already at this
case we're out of luck with using non PI
but the cool thing is if you have
certain numpy native d-type pen is
really fast and any you're you happy off
you can use pandas and it gives you
really good performance if it doesn't
support this then the performance is
mostly not so good the typical ones is
rivaling strings there is a fixed line
string
Piper numpy that's not exposed in part
in pandas but you can use fixed length
strings in non play but it has also
gives you than the maximum size each
string is as long as the maximum length
of an integer which can sometimes be
quite huge and also you can use multiple
instant planners the trick is to use
Python objects that's awfully slow but
you get malleable ins otherwise you get
a float array made out of integers that
so came sometimes if you're just doing
ad hoc data analysis but if you care a
lot about your types and you write
production code using pandas you really
want to be sure about the types and an
example of that is also visible and
behavior of Pinus - defaults to working
and fun doing things fast if you want to
have a data frame with a column update
pennis provides you with the date range
function then you have a data frame with
dates from 1970 up to now but if you
look at a data type which is in there
you can see in the middle of the
printout of panas it's a state I'm 64
nanoseconds yeah
dates and time zones are normally
fingers it's hard
and normally you assume that a time if
you're doing it right is represented in
UTC so if you say ok I want I have my
data frame I want to do some time sense
corrections to my local Mike a
supermarket then ok shift all timestamps
in my data frame to the local time zone
but if I'm dealing with dates a date
does not really have a time zone there
is just the first of January of 1970
anywhere on earth and you can't normally
put time zone on that because 10 cents
are plus minus hours so if you look at a
panda's data frame we were just
generated by that function you get a
time stamp
even though I wanted to date and this is
a bit where pandas loses types and in
trade-off for performance and the
solution for that is buying all those
things there is the date accessor and
you can call it and convert you want
column back to Python objects but a nice
thing at the end is you have a date and
then you don't you you take
time time sin conversion function won't
do anything with this column and you're
safe off
that's another typical example where
pandas type system is not as feature
full as you would like it
what already talks have minutes I ranted
a lot about this object type and a said
it's bad but really understand why it's
that we have to look at how this objects
look internally the really efficient
case is you have a numpy array in this
case with integers and then you have the
native performance and you have really
small overhead you have a big big thing
here which is only about I think forty
two bytes in memory is the Python object
declaring the number array which has
appointed to the data which has some
type meta information and then is the
dimension and Strides dimensions in this
case just a total of a single entry
saying it's a one-dimensional thing and
then you have one section memory which
is just plain c integers which is the
content of the number array if you in
contrast look at the Python list with
the same of these integers you have 40
bytes header for list pointing them to
an array in memory with memory addresses
just addresses so it's efficient local
to another but each of these addresses
pointed to Python integer objects in
memory and it can't be scattered
anywhere around in your memory and also
it's not a 64-bit integers eight bytes
but in the case here you have also the
40 byte memory overhead for Python
object so you actually have four inch
integer 48 bytes because just get around
a memory all the CPU caches you have
more to make you a numerical code fast
they fail because the just somewhere in
memory and it's not in termina state
data in one block of memory and to
access them you need two levels of
indirection in contrast to the numpy
array and that's why we need those fast
number array implementations to go to
get a good performance in pandas and all
number operations and that's then the
thing we missing at the moment with
types that have data object luckily
there was the Panda Co 24 lays I for a
pull request
months before that and it was really
really excited because at the moment if
you wanted to extend pandas you would
have to do a pull request which modifies
a lot of kindness internals or the
different approach would be what a
stupendous is doing subclass a data
frame and also overwrite some internals
of pandas and you need to have really
in-depth knowledge but pandas 0:23
it brought it to classes or interfaces
you have to implement just to and I will
show you also the methods you need to
implement which is really small and
there's the first one it's the d-type
which is just minimal matter of
information like what is the name of the
data type I'm getting and also what when
I'm accessing a cilium and do I get as a
Python object if you have a string you
normally want to have six dots text hive
in there to support the - to Python free
that's all you need for this extension
detail the extension array that's where
you actually have your payload data in
there there you have to keep drag off
your own memory in this case - reference
counted so keeping track of memory is
quite easy but you need some variables
and then provide some basic
implementation of the basic ground level
functionality not everything the pinus
API supports by the panas api builds on
some basic methods and once you
implement these basic methods you get
the whole panas api with all this fancy
group by things and so on which it did
not need to implement for your data type
and it's most kids it's really efficient
already from the start I will show a bit
of benchmarks for my one our string
implementation and it's already fast in
a pure string so this is a real
excitement it's much faster and maybe it
will be 10 times faster someday but it's
really a huge improvement and that's
also a huge improvement because it's so
fast to implement so all the functions
you need in pandas 0.23 to implement to
get a custom array this one's listed on
the left the upper two ones are just an
alias for constructors for special input
and then you have some ones for just get
items for complex at
using your data and returning maybe an
array of your type again or a single
scalar and then you have a bit meta
information and what is also important
is there is no function
The Pianist extensive array use this is
not function to infer if there is a
nulls or not nuts in your data this is
also really good if you want to provide
malleability because then your type can
just implement it how they would like
you don't have to provide like number of
features or for that and also what is
making it even better you get
test-driven development in just 10
seconds by just importing the tests
panas has huge set of tests which you
can just put your type and they have
little really big set of constraints
which you type [ __ ] at you and they
check everything with what's going in
there which makes it really easy to
implement it an extension array and
already get feedback if it's already
completely implemented and if you pass
those tests most of the functionality
will work but we have been using
numpy in pandas for a long while and
i've already said it's just focused on
numeric and matrices this is where
Apache arrow comes in there's a bit also
my motivation here I'm a patchy arrow
maintainer it's still a very low level
and as an end user you can I use it you
can I get a benefit because it's a
little low level library there's not
analytic on top arrow is just a
specification how you should put memory
or columnar memory in the into your RAM
and how you can also pass it around so
that it's independent from your
ecosystem you're actually living in if
you're in Java or if you're in implyin
it should have the same structure so you
can M ever it forwards and backwards and
it's also the design was taking in with
knowing what Python would our and Java
is using and also what the CPU wants to
be efficient and we have a lot of
languages supported now I'm not reading
all of them but I hope for it didn't
forget one of those we have a leased
prototype implementation our main
repository for them but the most typical
things at the PI data conference people
in our arrow for is like a format
reading and
since one or two months also the pet
panda CDF decorator which makes pie
spoke a bit faster the cool thing in
arrow is we have those types we're
missing in pandas so we have string type
we have a data type we have a nullable
int which is also improvement and we
also have some kind of recursive typing
like we can say we have a list of
something and we can put all those
primitive types we have an arrow inside
there and say we have a list of that we
have a struct container of these three
elements or union or so on which is much
bigger type system than num who provides
us and also it has the thing that
everything is malleable so if you're
dealing with MIT with missing data you
finally have these things you can set
flags okay this row is missing this
Rossen missing and also a bit coming
from the bigger data systems where you
get data and junked you can't if you
want to have a data memory consecutive
you would have to copy it once so in
arrow its built in that we also assume
that data will be charged so that if you
have an array it may be made out of two
memory sections makes it accessing
internally a bit harder but provides a
lot of some features that you can do
calculate a nation without everything
constant time and yeah as I mentioned
it's fast to just go to other systems
what's not so nice in Harrow is it's
still young it's two years old but it's
huge effort so for the huge effort it's
really young it there's not much
analytic on top - is about ten years old
so they had a lot of time to implement a
lot of analytic and error is really with
high performance the best forms can get
in mind written so it's modern C++ which
is nicer than old C++ but if you're just
working in Python it's really hard to
extent because you ever have to set up a
build environment and read through the
C++ code learn C++ again and then
compile and get a function it's not
really good if you want to do
interactive programming because we like
Python Python is is really easy to write
and just writing a function if maybe
it's not expressible with an umpire or
you just forgot how to express it with a
non pipe you can write a following PI
for
you get in result 240 milliseconds small
set of data so it sounds like it's fast
but actually normally or everyone knows
for loops of an umpire race is a no-go
it's slow and that's where the people
from continuum they have ridden number
number is a just-in-time compiler that
looks at your Python functions and
extracts autonomic operations out of
them and I comprised them with LLVM
which is the latest best compiler we
know about and the good thing is you
only need a cheat code decorator and
that's all the magic you have to do and
then it's a thousand times faster this
is a just an example a toy example
probably if you have more complicated
code it may be a lot more faster and it
may be a lot less faster but a good
thing is it's still for your site it's
pure Python there is a lot of C++ magic
behind that but you as an end user you
have pure Python the nice thing is
number does not need numpy race it needs
- memories views which could be any type
of memory as long as the implementer and
certain interface our arrays are bit
more complicated than Nampa arrays the
big difference here is a narrow string
array has free memory sections the first
is we have if not ability but for
another bility we also need an extra
layer of memory which is a valid bitmap
that's maybe a bit confusing if you were
talking about another better P but it's
a bitmap weight which is as a serial bit
for each entry if it's not if it's null
or not valid and a one if it's valid or
not null then because strings are
variable length and arrow we have first
and offset array which they see okay
this is an array
we're indicating where each string
starts and we have a second array which
the actual payload of the string we have
new characters utf-8 encoded meaning you
can use unsigned int eight and then you
can use the offset and take off set of
of your current index and offset of the
next index and get a length of the
string and there's also the magic that
we have an offset in there which is not
correlate
to the offsets above but an offset of
all your memory regions so if you just
slice an array you just incremented
offset and then you have a slice of an
error array don't need to make a copy
just a bit of CUNY Balan they get a bit
more complicated number Cox not just any
more edit but as a nice thing called did
class and number shitless is the
decorator where you have to supply types
it's not working with all types but then
you can define the members of your class
saying okay I have my first buffer which
is the develop bitmap all missing in my
case called the offsets which is an
inverted u in 32 and the data buffer
which is in UN date buffer which is made
me sometimes missing E in the case where
we have just only null values then we
don't need a data buffer and we have a
single scalar offset there's also always
the nice thing with number it's pure
Python code and you have only one
decorator indicating that you have a
just in time compiler working for you
for the rest of your class you can just
write pure Python functions even those
that do complicate a bit shifting
operations that access Daniel your
bitmap the weird thing is this function
is only valid in Python free but if you
use Python to have such a decorator it
works you can do from future imports but
that's a thing which confuse me
sometimes where I'm a unit test for
failing when I turned on code coverage
but this operations if you're doing it
in pure Python it's really slow and in
expressing a proof numpy is also not
really possible because that is a scalar
operation you want to check if one entry
in your array is null or not that's
maybe not really relevant at the moment
but the good thing is you can just take
your arrow array take this free memory
buffers and then create this object and
you can use it in for loops again just
as it was it would be a normal object
and to computer's length already said we
need to make one offset minus the other
offset we can just iterate over this
during array and call just one of those
member functions and the nice thing is
panis number is doing for us is
compelling them on the fly meaning we
have a complicated set of memory buffers
a clasp on top that defines us some some
member finds it on a scale level and we
can write a follow-up on that
and produces really fast CPU code which
is also using all the nice features with
the local CPU so if you have so kind of
new really you need a CPU that has avx2
this code will use it if you have just a
Python we love that it was compiled from
some other C++ code on on pipeline this
normally you won't use your modern CPU
instructions because it's built just for
working on all modern systems not on the
latest hardware which also gives you
some nice beat ups has a disadvantage is
a just-in-time compiler so you will have
some 100 microseconds 100 milliseconds
compiled time in the first call and we
can now put this all together we have an
interface and pandas which gives us the
possibility to extend planned us really
easily we have a storage layer which
defines some data structures and the
common typing system and we also have an
engine that can provide us algae to
write the basic functionalities you need
for this for fulfilling the interface of
pandas when I wrote this talk actually
for okay let's make a demo string type
maybe we get it working that it's that
we can't use a group operation on that
meanwhile the planners developers
proceeded and made this extension rate a
lot better and I happily saw that my
implementation for a string array wasn't
even using string type it was just using
arrow and was just using an arrow ray of
any type so at the end what I made is I
started making a library which was first
released last night which you can
actually input any arrow data and it
provides generic function early on on
all of those arrow data to put it into
number pandas it does not work for all
types for example nullable
is only possible also since last night
on pandas master because if you're using
some of those types that are also
supported by an umpire there's some
special optimizations and pandas which
crash if you're not really numpy but
just implementing the nan PI interface
but the nice thing is working with it is
really easy so I'm I'm not doing live
demo I'm using my slides I'm not as good
as James who can just code and talk
again at the same time the user
interface is for those extension Ares
it's really good written by pandas the
main thing you have to provide is wrap
your data in a class that fulfills the
interface and here I have an array
called data which just takes Wren is a
set of random single letter strings and
I'm putting in my data frame I have an
object column which uses just numpy
array with the type object and have a
Fletcher Fletcher standing of my library
which wraps this and passes it to do
constructed a construct disease that's
it's a Python object and then converts
it to arrow it's not the most efficient
way to construct it but it's quite easy
one year if you have arrow date already
read written read from Rockefeller so
you don't need to convert it back to
Python you can just use it and put put
it also in a flash array and pandas
looks at all those data looks if it's an
extension array and if it's one it will
just load it as an extension array and
dealing with distributes strings then
these you just the same result and we
have just test we fulfilled in and so if
you look at the data frame we have a lot
of singer character strings and if you
have an object column or if you have one
of my flashier columns there's no
difference in looking at it if you look
from the optical perspective if you look
on the info information from a data
frame you see that the first column is
of object D type and the second column
is my magic slash a string type and we
have a memory usage 80 megabytes this is
also a thing with objects as I told you
you have a lot of overhead with type
objects I mean if you get rid of that
overhead
you save a lot of memory and we have
about it's four bytes overhead for a
Fletcher string and it's 42 bytes for a
normal - string that explains a bit of
difference and also we have Python
strings at utf-16 and I think in the
most modern pythons and arrow using
utf-8 that's a bit of trickery sometimes
beneficial sometimes not but for memory
usage it's really beneficial so meaning
at the end that my customer ray is about
ten times smaller than the pandas array
and it even works and I haven't spent
any time yet in performance tuning I
just called a group by and said okay I
have this caller of in sender so give me
just as some group by the singer
characters in the beginning and with
exactly the same data and you can see
with my Fletcher array which doesn't use
Python objects you get about half the
time you have with a typical array and
the weird thing is which also gives a
bit of performance boost maybe in future
there are a lot of conversions where the
string array or a subset of string array
is still converted to an umpire object
array that's where you can hook and to
pandas and say okay my type is a bit
more mightier and I can provide more of
the core functionality which I don't
have to but I can with an expansionary
and that will give us even the chance to
make this string type even faster what a
nice thing is I just implemented the
call functions some even in pure
polyphen it's already a lot faster than
having the typical Python implementation
um and I'm not the only one this started
out from experior for anaconda
I had a task to build an RP type in
pandas this was the initiation for all
this extension array and tamaak tum'
also has build the extension every
support meaning that there is a package
from continue more now anaconda
called cyber pandas it brings you an IP
and a mega ray and G openness is looking
at with a pull request that this
geometry array which is used into your
penis is not any more implemented by sub
classing but by just providing an
extension array meaning that you also
can can be
these types in a normal ordinary data
frame in future my life libraries link
down here and also words maybe even up
to you if you have data that is not just
fitting into a panda's data frame I can
really say to you just try it maybe if
you have two or three hours to spend
just have a look if you can implement
something really nice panas extensions
array that you could implement could be
a constant array which is just an array
pretending to be large but has it's just
consists of a single value and that's
often the case if you have like kind of
one hot encoding or so and you have a
feature which is not used but you still
need it in your pandas array and then
you just make considere you can
implement it on your own and save a lot
of memory yeah and as I said last slide
was late I haven't spent all night on
writing it just last night my my code
past so since the day you can pip
install Fletcher and you can use strings
and lists and pandas and also if you
have you with kindness master you get
Nala berlin's yeah but don't use it in
production it will break everything it's
it's tested it has 100% code coverage or
90% code coverage but a lot of edge
cases which is not covered by all the
tests and a lot of edge cases very it's
probably really slow but I'm quite happy
that it wasn't so much effort to bring
in eight of string type to pandas and
yeah one of commercial at the end Alex
already mentioned it sometimes we have a
PI data and PyCon incarcerate end of the
year and like it was just last minute
with this talk and PyCon I will also
talk about how you can work on data
allocated in Java without copying in
pandas prototype is already working but
not for Strings and so on but I hope I
get it until then so and that was my
talk thank you
[Applause]
thanks so much over for the talk that
was super fascinating are there any more
questions that you will like that I
talked rest for you I heard the arrow
mentioned in several talks and I'm quite
excited about it and I would like to use
it so I was trying to find some examples
of how to use arrow but somehow I didn't
find them so if you can give some
recommendations how to get started with
this
so for arrow as an end user it there's
not so much much functionality so the
main examples how to use arrow actually
in this talk now because that's how you
can use arrow and pandas but the other
thing where you can use arrow is to open
package files or to connect to a
database that supports ODBC or you can
use it in pant and in spark by using a
decorator but it's at the moment it's
still a system-level library so if you
need really good performance and you
have time to spend look into it
contribute to it but as an end user you
have to wait a bit for it or you have to
also engage in development to get it
ready for an end user it's a whole foot
project it's a long-term project so if
everything goes through it will provide
a lot of performance by the moment it's
not so visible Thanks
we just had a talk here about R and
Python and how he can use both together
but if you start out with - the problem
is if you have for example a big pandas
dataframe and you want to do some
analysis using an our library you
duplicate memory and you just told us
that you have this magnificent tool
where you can share a memory is there
something on the horizon that we could
use avoiding you know duplication when
you want to kind of use code in both
languages together there is actually two
tools in there the first thing is you
can use arrow that's already a feather
format which is also arrow which you can
use to dump arrow to disk and load again
you can use the same code if you just
don't dump this data to this but pass it
between our replacement there are sadly
no code but the other thing is also
there is a block marriage and pandas the
block management penance is doing magic
things and probably more to complicate
it into explaining nail answer but you
these extensions array are not really
managed by the block manager which means
that you have a bit you're taking care
of managing the memory and not pianist
is taking care you can actually just
probably just try and write an extension
array which just uses the our column and
purchase as an extension into pandas
then you probably would get no copy from
our but still native pandas so thanks a
lot when we also know now weird whom to
call thanks a lot for your talking also
my twitter username follow me then you
will get our slides thank you the code
you showed us had all these nice for
loops and I'm correct but we shouldn't
use for loops and haven't at all so if
you do an iterator is there the same
speed advantage and also if you try to
vectorize everything as much as possible
already in pandas will you still have as
you know 10x savings or will that then
be less if
using number you won't have those ten
egg saving if you already have written
perfect Richter s code but it even is
useful sometimes to write for loops with
number because if you have a number
array and you do vector s operations
after each operations your results are
copied to a new array and if you use
number and write followed you will pull
the mem data once from memory do in your
local CPU registers the computations and
then push it once back to memory which
makes it a lot faster because you have
less intermediate locations but that's
normally that they overhead is more
effective to yourself which is not
always beneficial to write more
complicated code